une foule à n'ont pu voir le bout
manifestent contre l'imposition du port
du masque pour lutter contre le coc vide
19 ce samedi à berlin
ils étaient plus de 38000 selon les
autorités à défiler dans les rues pour
demander la fin de toutes les
restrictions mises en place
nous pensons que le corona et comme une
grippe grave et c'est comme ça que nous
aimerions en discuter les mesures sont
complètement exagéré pourquoi ne voulons
pas eu ces mesures l'année dernière où
il ya trois ans lorsque 25000 personnes
sont mortes
cela aurait pu être fait à ce moment là
aussi c'est de cette façon ouverte que
nous aimerions voir cela débattue ceci
ne devrait pas se produire en allemagne
et c'est pour cela que nous nous battons
ce regroupement mêlant corona sceptiques
et mi-temps d'ultra droite a ensuite
dégénéré
des affrontements ont eu lieu avec les
forces de l'ordre
300 personnes ont été interpellées mais
aucun blessé a été recensé dans la
capitale britannique
un millier de personnes ont demandé je
cite la fin de la tyrannie médicale
alors qu'en suisse les manifestants ont
dénoncé une dictature sanitaires c'est
pas une politique c'est une dictature ça
viole nos droits constitutionnels sa
viole nos droits de liberté ça viole nos
droits à la salle à la réunion on
n'avait même pas le drap réunir des
signatures pour les univers initiatives
et référendums
c'était un d'urgence est une abomination
ça c'est un viol nous tout tous les
principes démocratiques
c'est une rupture du pacte social c'est
cette rupture du contrat social c'est un
coup d'état permanent contre les peuples
mondiaux sous couvert d'une flotte
l'endémique est pas vrai qu'il n'existe
pas enfin à paris 200 à 300 personnes
ont manifesté contre le port obligatoire
du masque alors je suis pas contre le
masque je suis entre l'obligation au
port du masque surtout qu'il impose à un
moment où on n'a pas forcément besoin
c'est la fin de la pandémie alors que au
mois de mars avril quand on était en
plein pic épidémique
il n'y avait pas de masque il
interdisait aux pharmaciens de le vendre
donc voilà il impose maintenant c'est
pas ça très logique
présente sur place les forces de l'ordre
ont encerclé les manifestants
elles ont verbalisé certains d'entre eux
d'une amende de 135 euros
la raison ne pas avoir porter de masque